next story is a serious one um
please be cautious about young viewers
it is not suitable for them
it also might be triggering for
survivors of domestic violence and
sexual assault but it is a very
important story to share and
thank you to actress evan rachel wood
who is speaking about her allegations of
abuse against former fiance marilyn
manson and for the first time in her new
documentary phoenix rising
evan opens up about the shocking details
please look at her story
actress and model evan rachel wood has
made a name for herself as a rising star
in hollywood since childhood at 14 she
was cast in the teen movie 13 a breakout
role that launched her into the media
spotlight and years later it caught the
attention of rock star marilyn manson
in 2006 at just 18 evan met the then 37
year old manson for four years the
parent made headlines for their on and
off again romance they were briefly
engaged before finally calling it quits
in 2010.
speculation intensified about their
relationship in 2016 when evan began to
speak out on behalf of survivors of
sexual assault
in 2018 she testified in front of
congress that a former partner gaslit
brainwashed and even raped her while
unconscious
my abuser was very sadistic and
calculated
and
would threaten me blackmail me
but it wasn't until february 1st 2021
that evan named marilyn manson as her
abuser for the first time in her new
documentary phoenix rising evan alleges
that she was threatened raped drugged
and tortured at the hands of her former
fiancee
evan is not alone more than a dozen
women have also come forward with their
own stories of alleged abuse by manson
and several women have filed lawsuits
against him manson has denied all the
allegations of abuse against him and
insists that all of his relationships
were consensual he recently filed his
own lawsuit against evan and another
woman accusing them of conspiracy
infliction of emotional distress and
defamation
evan has said that she will no longer be
silenced by fear of retaliation and is
sharing her story to stand with all
survivors and show they are not alone
welcome to the show thank you for having
me you have been out there sort of
promoting this documentary yes
so there's so much that comes out in the
documentary about your relationship with
marilyn manson brian warner
and there's so many wonderful things
about our business you're still doing it
i'm still doing it absolutely
but there is a
submissive mind game performing people
pleasing
no boundaries oddity of
you do what you're told
so
growing up that way
what was that like for you set the stage
because it
feels like is that such an odd catalyst
for
what happened with you and marilyn uh
absolutely and that's why it was
important for me to tell that side of
the story because uh otherwise we're
just treating the symptoms and not and
not the the root and that's why it goes
into my background it also goes into
brian's background to understand
how we got here and you know what was
the polarity that that created this
lightning
um
and uh i mean you really
hit the nail on the head i i uh i think
it was yama van sant who said this once
and i'm obsessed with her in the work
she does with family but she was
speaking to somebody and she said you
grew up you weren't raised
and that hit me in such a deep place
because i realized that i had to grow up
so quickly
and i was being rewarded and taught sort
of all the wrong lessons for a young
woman which was uh the less boundaries i
had the more love i would receive
the more successful i would be the more
i would be taken seriously if i said no
i was being difficult if i was obedient
i was being good yeah and these things
and so and that's a very dangerous
environment to be raised in because then
you end up a young adult
uh a child in a woman's body essentially
such easy prey
and i was 18 when i met brian and
legally i'm an adult but i have lived no
life as an adult
[Music]
you